CRAIG BOX: Anthos is Google
Cloud's new open platform
that lets you run an
app anywhere, simply,
flexibly, and securely.
With Anthos, we bring
the cloud to you.
As an enterprise, you
need to move faster.
The expected time to market
for products and services
has shortened dramatically
from years to days.
With the growth
of mobile clients,
you are now serving hundreds
to billions of users
concurrently, rather than
making copies on disks.
But today, you move at the
speed of your slowest develop.
Cloud is a way to
put the pedal down.
The cloud is
wonderful for people
who are building
everything from scratch.
But you might have
decades of investment
in your existing data centers.
You are forced into making
trade-offs-- security
versus agility, reliability
versus cost, portability
versus consistency.
The news is you don't have
to move to the cloud today.
Moving to a microservices
architecture,
you can let each team work
at the speed that suits them.
Believe it or not, Google
started out this way, too,
and we have a lot of
investment in data centers.
Changing the way we
wrote our applications
meant we could move quicker
and scale out to more locations
to serve our global
customer base.
Along the way, we pioneered
a thing called a container.
Containers are a way of bundling
an application for deployment
on a server.
If you write software
in something like Java,
you might do this today.
Instead of using an application
server like Tomcat or WebSphere
and bundling your
application into a JAR file,
you build your application
into a container
and run it on a
container runtime.
Normally, an application
server handles
clustering, load balancing, and
resource management for you.
But that's only for
applications on the JVM.
Containers, on the
other hand, run directly
on the operating
system kernel, meaning
you can put any
application in them.
You don't need to have
a different deployment
system for apps written
in different languages
or binaries versus things
you've built from source.
Now you just need an application
server to run these containers,
and that's where
Kubernetes comes in.
Kubernetes deals
with all the stuff
that your application
server worried about,
and it does so in
a declarative way.
You tell it what
you want to run,
and it makes sure that you
always have what you asked for.
You could think of
Kubernetes as the kernel
of the new distributed
application platform.
As with all software, you need
to install, manage, and operate
your Kubernetes environment.
You need to manage the nodes
through things like kernel
and operating system upgrades.
The manual management
of Kubernetes
can be resource-intensive.
So in 2015, we launched Google
Kubernetes Engine in the cloud.
GKE allows users to
focus on clusters
rather than administration.
And now, people have
come back and said,
I want GKE, but
in my data center.
So we've taken it
a step further.
GKE On-Prem is GKE running
in your data center.
It's managed by Google's
world-class engineering team,
but it runs on your own
hardware, behind your firewall,
and integrates with your
existing networking, storage,
and identity systems.
You can build your own
apps into containers.
You can deploy any container
image from a public repository.
Or you can deploy a variety
of supported applications
using the GCP marketplace.
Whatever you want
to do, GKE On-Prem
lets you deploy and scale in
seconds, hundreds of times
a day, and potentially
increase resource utilization
by up to 75%.
Kubernetes alone isn't enough.
It helps you run
applications, but you still
have to manage them.
You need to handle identity
and access management
for those applications
and debug your clusters
when things go wrong.
On top of that, your
teams are looking at cloud
and seeing the new
serverless offerings.
So Google has launched
Anthos, a single platform
for running wherever you are.
Modernization journeys
can be daunting.
But with the power of open
software, orchestration,
and containerization,
Google brings you
the power to modernize,
both on-premises as well
as in the cloud, while
moving at a pace you
are comfortable with.
To learn more about
Kubernetes and GKE, please
subscribe to our channel.